[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
just standing on chiswick high road in
london
outside a commercial building and above
the commercial building
there's two blocks of flats that's all
owned by the same landlord
and one of my students andre you may
have seen him on the eviction
he was evicted and he said he was the
strongest contestant i said he was the
weakest
maybe he was the strongest after all
because he's actually secured this
direct to landlord on a rent to rent
basis
he'll be making him around about 1
900 pounds a month profit when it's
fully talented
he's just secured it he's just secured
some tenants let's find out what's going
on
yes how are you doing is that a tenant
that is
so you're renting these rooms out like
crazy now i've got four rented out i've
got four left
man it's cold
super excited for samuel lee's to come
see my two apartments that i've just
secured
there's one on top of the other on this
big commercial building i'm happy to
have you here i'm stoked so you so
you've basically
the downstairs is not yours no but
you've controlled the
upstairs and the top floor right
complete show me show me show
cool so this looks like lifting is there
people living here already
yeah oh i thought you just secured this
i just secured another tennis and
straight away
okay nice so how long did it take to get
tenants
well i've done the refurbs for about
three weeks so the partition this table
chairs i've done a quite a big refurb
but from when it was uh finished
it took a week and a bit a week and two
days to get
four tenants in there but i'll show you
just the smallest bedroom
okay cool it's really nice though
it's small but you do it to a quite high
standard haven't you yeah and what i've
done is
because i saved a bit of money uh with
the dressings of the beds
i only ordered two and then i moved them
around on each bed and took the pictures
so it looks like every room has been
dressed great so basically you market it
and market it as all furnished with the
bedding
yeah but then when they go to move in
you say by the way you're gonna have to
bring your own bedding
you have it there for the pictures and
for the display but you tell them
when they move in they're gonna have to
bring their own bedding yeah and you
just move it around from room to room
that's right why do you do that
why it saves me money i'm buying more
dressing
yeah and it works so it also is less
hassle because
when people are moving in and moving out
if you have to keep getting new bedding
yeah hassle it's expense people don't
usually mind bringing their own bedding
yeah no i mean i i explain it once
they're here once they
secure the room yeah i tell them that
the bedding
they've got the mattress they've got the
best these are all new i've just ordered
them
yeah um but they need to bring their own
bed in yeah yeah yeah
and what's with the plants what made you
decide to go with the plant kind of vibe
because it just makes the room look ten
times nicer i don't know
what it is about the plants but it makes
it look much nicer it's like life
isn't it yeah i like it and this is the
smallest room
yeah this is a smaller stream yeah how
much how much you renting this out for
600 pounds okay and how can you justify
charging 600 pounds for a room
it's in chiswick park three minutes walk
from the station and
turn them green park is one minute away
and you've got sainsbury's superstore
two minutes away it's literally on the
high street you've got all the stores
um local transport the rooms here i'm
probably charging the least
out of everyone in the area but that's
only because i want to fill them up go
and get more properties
okay love it when you said you had to
refurb it
like how much how much money do you
spend on the refurb um
in total four thousand pounds okay so
it's quite a big investment well that's
two flats so two thousand each okay it's
not bad i guess you'll make that money
back after like about two months
and then you're just making one nine
each month profit 1 900 which is
to be fair it's a full-time salary yeah
it's very good not bad i'm happy about
it so we can't go in the ensuite room
because it's rented out already yes how
much rent are you getting
9.50 9.50 very nice
so how much rent are you getting for
this entire apartment
so for this apartment alone i'm getting
two thousand
eight hundred pounds per month and
what's the breakdown with that then so
this the ensuite 950 right so 950
plus um 700 plus six
fifty plus six hundred two
two two nine two nine sorry two thousand
nine hundred pounds
i'm getting just for this apartment
alone and i've got plus the upstairs as
well
nice so you're getting a lot of rent how
much are you paying the landlady in
total for the two apartments
three thousand seven hundreds okay but
then you're renting it out for like five
and a half
ish so on the upstairs apartment i'm
getting 9.50
on this one i'm getting about eight
hundreds okay
well that's solid man yeah that's really
solid and i guess that's taking into
account voyage and stuff
um but you're not expecting many boys no
i've got four rooms now in about
in the space of a weekend so it might be
a little bit more than that i mean who
knows but it's really good it's good to
be conservative with your numbers
yes because you you bear it you're
better to be overly surprised
than to factor in not factory mountains
not factoring voids and then end up
being like oh man i'm breaking even
you know so really good going
so this is the second flat
yeah my smallest bedroom so
this room i'm actually gonna advertise
it for 650 pounds
yeah so this room alone will be 650
you can see i've added some lamps and
features to make the room look nice new
furniture
and i'm getting a lot of demand straight
away so people have asked for this room
so hopefully within the next two three
days i expect
no no longer than that so well you were
like doing viewings when i arrived do
you really like showing people around
i got a tenant before you arrived two
minutes before you arrived
she's like i can't transfer the money my
phone so i'm like let's go to the atm
she got gone to the atm she pulled took
the money out of
her card and gave it to me in cash nice
so i just
i secured the next room which i'll show
you now yeah show
this is me box by the way this is my
lovely room so she's just literally just
paid for this in cash
yeah so this this one i'm writing out
for 700
yeah and yeah how much did how much
money did you take off with us now well
i took 150 pound security deposit
yeah but she's going home charging her
phone and once the contracts get signed
she's gonna pay me one month's rent and
one month's deposit right
how did you get the money to
you know do this place up where did that
money come from so
i had some of my own not i had to about
2 000 on my own which i paid the
deposits for
and the rest of the money has come from
my dad which i said to him
if you borrow it to me i'll give it to
you back
so it's a loan yeah and i've calculated
that as a loan so i've used my dad's
money to
describe finance this deal and why did
your dad feel confident in you to give
you the money
do you think for this well um i
explained the deal to him
even though he doesn't really understand
how it works
i i tried to explain him the best way i
could and
because i'm his son he just gave me a
shot so he's like
i'll give you the money you'll pay me
back in your own time
but i'll help you with these deals and
see if it goes well i'll
i'll help you on awesome that's great
but this was a really nice room
i can see why she took it but
it's got that nice new furniture smell
yeah
you can smell it so this one's rented
out or yeah
900 900. it's crazy it's really really
good
i think that the thing is when you're
doing this in london
the rent is higher that you need to pay
to the landlord yeah but then you're
going to be able to get a higher rent as
well
so the the profit you can make a lot of
profit doing this in london
now i've filled in four rooms in a space
of a week
one week and two days and that
that was with the um now i've reduced
the price slightly for
some of the rooms which is still making
me the profit i've just mentioned or
else it would have been even more
yeah i would have been hitting 2 000 a
month but
i've had i'm getting about 10 to 15
messages a day
it's funny that you're getting that many
messages in the middle of a lockdown
yeah
yeah so what i've done is i've made
multiple ads not all of this property so
there's two ads one of this
uh property and one of the downstairs
and i've put another four
different ads in the area so acton
turn them green so it grabs the
attention
of people in the area looking for rooms
and when they request
to view that i say actually i've got
this one in chisholm because that's been
fully
reserved and then it's bringing more
attention i'm getting more tenants in
the internet
very cool it sounds almost as spammy as
the way you got on the eviction
but now that's great the best the best
thing about the room is the bathroom
this has been recently renovated by the
landlord they've spent four thousand
pounds on the renovation
yeah on this bathroom talking about the
landlord
or the landlady i should say london lady
and lord yeah
how how did you manage to secure this
deal like what did you do
how did you find her how did you get the
deal so i called her from gumtree
yeah and i scheduled in a viewing she
was a bit
skeptical when she saw me at my age
because i look a bit young
how old are you well i'm 21. yeah so
they were quite old they were sort of in
their 70s 80s
um and when they saw me they they were a
bit uncomfortable they didn't know what
i'm talking
like because i explained it in a very
simple straightforward way
and i offered her something she couldn't
refuse
yeah compared to the competitors then
she decided to go with me
i've also brand my family to
for the landlord to meet my family my
mom and dad so that it builds a bit of
trust
and then once they saw my family they
were happy to go ahead and footage but
that's fine
so there are tenants in some of the
rooms they're sleeping so we're gonna go
back downstairs
yeah there's one room that you could um
book on um so
i'll i'll send you the pictures to the
rooms right now i've got a meeting so i
can't i can't stay for
yeah so i've just got a meeting in about
a minute so i what i can do is i'll
i'll fold them the info on whatsapp and
the images
and then just let me know which room you
like most and we'll get in touch again
no that'll be great perfect all right
thank you
take care bye bye bye yeah these phones
don't stop pinging you've got people
wanting to move in left right and center
yeah all
the time
the way they leave their kitchens really
good it is very tidy
yeah we've done really well and this is
this your first rental rent
this is my first year great first two
rents are entered yes
there's two rental ramps and how you
know where did this all come from like
how did you manage to
you know have the you know um to
actually secure these and get it from
how does this come about aft once i was
in the eviction
we were working like that was crazy the
amount of work we were putting in
so when we left when i got evicted i'm
like
okay fair enough i got evicted even
though i thought i was the strongest
link
but i need to prove that anyway so as
soon as i left
i because we done directed vendor we
were calling director vendors for the
lease options
that gave me the idea to do that with
the rent to rent because i kept getting
rejected from the agents because they're
like you can't pass reference in
each time so i went direct to landlords
and i presented myself well
and they they were happy to give me the
properties excellent and you've also
secured
with your brother yes what a lease
option agreement
i trained him with the training you gave
me i gave him the same training at home
and i said try this call these agents
i told him how to find the negative
equity deals
so he called up in a matter of seven
calls
he had secured the lease option and uh
he's got a memorandum
signed with the landlord incredible so
that was the
lease option boot camp yes recycled
training recycle training yeah
fabulous though really it's really good
i mean once you the best gift you can
give to your family
is your personal development and your
education so it's really good you've got
your dad on board your brother on board
what's next
what's next i've got a target to hit and
i will hit it so you can remember me
i'm going to have 22 returns by the end
of this year so winners wednesday is
going to be very soon oh yeah definitely
as soon as these are filled i've got
already eight properties that lined up
already
with an agent that's happy to give me
the given all of the properties to me so
i'll be taking on two next and then
another two and another two and another
two
excellent and you'll just see me growing
my business
very quickly so there we have it folks
endrip
secured two rental rents here these are
the properties got
loads more in the pipeline going ahead
you'll see them on winners on a
wednesday
if you want to be on winners on a
wednesday and you want to get the same
training that entry had
i'd rick i recommend you come down to
the property investors crash course have
you been on the crash course
i have yes i've been twice actually how
do you find it
amazing um definitely if you're starting
up in property
and you want to learn i learned a lot
about hmos back then when i came to the
crash course
and networking as well you meet all
sorts of people doing the same
same types of business as you're doing
so sourcing hmos
investment you can find loads of
business partners and
it is definitely worth going to the
crash course
yeah learning and also meeting new
people so here's what i'm going to say
i'm going to leave a link in the
description
with free tickets to the property
investors crash course it's also
virtual i'm going to be there get on
there it's free i'll leave it in the
description
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video you'll probably like this video up
here as well
so check that out also don't forget to
subscribe right here
and book on to the property investors
crash course i'll see you there
thanks for watching